el limpieza o función político que en
realidad se da en el senado tiene dos
posibilidades una opción es la de
remover en el cargo a una autoridad a un
oficial público que es lo que influye el
presidente de la república en el caso
del sistema constitucional
estadounidense o también e inhabilitarlo
esto que se da en las constituciones
duplicadas en la figura de la
inhabilitación para el ejercicio de
cargo público futuro y entonces podría
ser ambas posibilidades ahora lo que sí
es cierto es este hecho el digamos esto
este asalto el capitolio es percibido
casi como un autogolpe la figura aquí en
lamentablemente en democracia es un poco
más débil es mucho el caso de las
latinoamericanas se da como el nombre
del autogolpe decir cuando un jefe de
estado propicia un quiebre institucional
para
permanecer en el poder o en todo caso
para desconocer el resultado electoral
que es propiamente el caso del señor
trans no ha estado ha explicado una
estrategia la regla de conocimiento del
resultado electoral ha acusado de cosas
falsas y en este caso públicamente
estaba alentando actos de violencia para
resistirse
al proceso constitucional o el resultado
electoral entonces hay también este
aspecto que es súper importante que este
punto de inflexión que ha que ha dejado
muy golpeada a la democracia
norteamericana que hay que decirlo es
una democracia emblemática de la más
antigua del mundo y además siempre fue
un sistema paradigmático toda buen
funcionamiento del sistema
representación pero en los últimos en
las últimas décadas hemos visto que ha
habido bastantes complicaciones y
particularmente en este caso el señor
tram implica un punto inflexión porque
se ha roto esa estabilidad y ese respeto
al orden constitucional que
tradicionalmente ha caracterizado 6000
es eso creo también en no dejar que esto
pase como un hecho regular tiene que
haber una sanción política para eso está
pensado estos impeachment o juicios
políticos que en realidad sea en esta
segunda cámara no hay un plazo así que
esto no creo que sea corto no creo que
sea pronto pero tiene que dar una
respuesta ahora el problema es bastante
más complejo es una sociedad escindida
en la que digamos empobrecido y por lo
tanto al igual como pasó en la segunda
guerra mundial esto da mucho miedo en el
caso de alemania si tú eres muy
empobrecido logran generar el insumo
humano para el surgimiento de estos
estos regímenes infractores de la
constitución uno incluso decantan en
totalitarismo esto parece que se ha dado
de eeuu y no solamente se enseñan se ya
estaría incitando como se le ha acusado
porque ya tiene una acusación a nivel de
la de abogado en representantes y ahora
ya de nivel desde el senado se va
realmente a llevar el juicio político no
encendido está abogado nos quedan unos
45 segundos disculpe que lo interrumpa
le quería preguntar sobre la presidencia
de trump pues deja un partido
republicano fracturado evidenciado por
el voto de 10 republicanos de la cámara
baja en su contra puede el partido darse
el lujo de darse la espalda a donald
trump ya su movimiento político reiteró
nos quedan 40 segunditos es cumplir la
pregunta realmente complicada y hay que
pensar que también es la decisión que
sea de ensenada es política en este caso
es un juicio político y que va a ser
sujeto del señor tram es complicado
porque entran tiene algún respaldo
electoral interesante no y él ha
demostrado que no se siente totalmente
republicano si no se siente tram pista o
sea ni en un movimiento como propio
ciertamente esto
ha fracturado el partido republicano
como usted bien lo señala hay 222 votos
demócratas en la cámara de
representantes para aprobar la acusación
también tienen votos republicanos se
sumaron hay un partido descendido pero
hay que decir una cosa no es persona
pública no durante todos estos últimos
cuatro años mientras ha ido mintiendo
sistemáticamente respecto a varios temas
ha sido bastante digamos este flexible
de modo tal yo creo que finalmente es
posible que giren ese entorno es
imposible que giren en torno a su a su
forma de liderazgo que sin duda no es
democrático
pues muchas gracias a los votos para hay
muchas gracias lo interrumpo nuevamente
gracias por su análisis por su
comprensión al abogado
constitucionalista